[Applause]
[Music]
people come people go
it's a fact of life dear friends there
are few places in the world in which you
can appreciate the games the power plays
the rivalry between nations as well as
you can in the Middle East
[Music]
without a doubt this is a region that
has become one of the greatest chess
boards of international politics and it
makes sense when you think about it they
have all of the essential elements the
Middle East is located at the crossroads
of three distinct continents it's the
largest source of hydrocarbons in the
world
it's an enclave through which a great
deal of international trade passes and
it's the heartland of one of the biggest
religions on the planet and that's not
even mentioning that it's got a huge
piggyback
[Music]
energy commerce money religion the
Middle East has really become an
international player in recent decades
and to top it off we're talking about a
place that has traditionally been a
hornet's nest and in recent years this
penchant for drama has only increased
the truth is that today you would be
hard-pressed to find a more conflictive
place in the world and no I'm not
exaggerating take a look at the historic
conflicts between Israel and Palestine
in recent years we could add the war in
Syria and the war in Yemen to the list
and let's not forget the chaos that the
Islamic state caused when its leader Abu
Bakr al-baghdadi declared the
restoration of the Caliphate and invaded
much of Iraq and Syria but it doesn't
end there in addition the Gulf
Cooperation Council has been fractured
by the growing conflict between Qatar in
the United Arab Emirates in Saudi Arabia
a conflict that has ended in the rupture
of almost all relations between the
countries and a savage blockade there
was the Iran cold war Iraqi Kurdistan
trying to proclaim its
self-determination and arrogance Turkey
facing off against NATO and invading
Syria in other words there are conflicts
galore of all sizes and all colors if
you want a fight you know where to find
it however all of this chaos is hiding a
very important change that has slowly
begun in the Middle East
[Music]
you see in recent decades the great
American Empire has had a very strong
hand in controlling the region but now
silently and without attracting
attention things are beginning to shift
and all because another Empire is on the
scene
now both empires are fighting for
control of the Middle East using very
different strategies - listen up
[Music]
the arrival of the eastern empire
in 2016 the Chinese government published
the Arab policy paper its first
political strategy documents for the
Middle East here on visual politic we've
been telling you for a long time how the
Chinese government is slowly unfurling
its tentacles across the entire planet
what we've also told you that the growth
of the Chinese economy is slowing down
which is forced China to curb its
investments abroad business happens
elsewhere in the world except for one
place the Middle East and there's a very
good reason for this right here on
YouTube you can find very interesting
documentaries such as how Nazi Germany
was forced to invest huge amounts of its
resources to produce synthetic oil from
coal and right there was Germany's
Achilles heel the lack of fuel without
energy there can be no power there can
be no prosperity and in a way that's a
modern problem - China is the second
biggest consumer of oil right behind the
United States the difference is that
China are unlike the US or even Russia
has increasingly had to import more and
more oil to meet its needs
to give you an idea today half of the
oil that China consumes comes from the
Middle East
[Music]
and it's not just oil the exact same
thing happens with natural gas in 2019
China will become the world's largest
natural gas importer across the globe
China accounts for 1/3 of the world's
natural gas demands and things are
expected to become even worse in the
future you see the Chinese economy is an
economy that has been built on coal want
to hear a curious fact since 2011 China
consumes more coal than all other
countries in the world put together
[Music]
the problem as you all know is that coal
is a tremendously polluting energy
source and this not only impacts climate
change but also the quality of life and
health of Chinese citizens some days
these cities seem to have been built
inside of a fireplace that's precisely
why the government is pushing to replace
this energy source with cleaner
alternatives renewable energies nuclear
energy and natural gas in other words
China's energy dependence is and will be
one of this country's biggest weaknesses
so you can already see how important it
is for the Chinese government to control
and guarantee its oil and natural gas
sources if supply to these resources
were impeded all the power and
prosperity of the Asian giant would
collapse when the Chinese government
debates national security they have to
talk about energy
[Music]
and there's also one other very
important detail China isn't the only
Asian nation that depends on energy
supplies without delving too deep to of
its neighbors and greater rivals have
even higher dependence levels
in japan's case their dependence on
Middle Eastern oil exceeds 90% of its
consumption and in India's case 60% let
me explain this another way controlling
a hydrocarbon sources could not only be
useful to China from the security of
supply point of view but also as a
geopolitical instruments and of course
when all this depends largely on a
region riddled with so many problems
well let's just say that Beijing
understood it was high time to get a
foothold in the Middle East even more so
if we consider that the country with the
most influence over this region right
now is its biggest rival in the United
States
[Music]
but that's not the only reason there's
another reason that explains China's
growing interest in the petro monarchies
region ensuring the safety of their
trade routes as you know that Chinese
economy is very focused on exports well
a substantial part of all Chinese trade
passes directly through the Middle East
and in order for trade to flow China
depends on both the ports and the so
called choke points in that area
these are critical points in many supply
chains and if arrivals such as the
United States were able to close them it
would interrupt most of China's trade
both inbound and outbound we're talking
about places such as the Suez Canal that
meant it straight or almost straight and
keep in mind that these are waters full
of American naval ships
why now this scenario doesn't seem
likely but it's a risk that the Chinese
authorities are already considering for
these two reasons the Middle East has
become a level one priority for the
Chinese government but at this point the
question that pops up is well how does
the Chinese government want to do this
what is the Chinese government doing to
expand its influence in this region
[Music]
China's power paths in the field of
international politics the strategy that
the Chinese follow to achieve their
objectives is different from what we
used to you see China doesn't want to
gain control in the Middle East by using
its army instead it wants to use a very
different mechanism there's nothing new
they've been doing it all over the world
the Asian giant wants to create a
culture of economic independence one so
strong that it can give China enormous
influence among the region's countries
this is an interdependence that
guarantees full access to and in some
ways control of all the oil and natural
gas they need this explains why China
has positioned itself as the largest
investor in the region since 2017 that's
even above the United States itself one
out of every three euros that are
invested in the Middle East come from
Chinese money
it's the only region in which Chinese
foreign investment continues to grow
steadily for example in 2016 the Chinese
company Sina packin to the Saudi company
Aramco agreed to jointly build a
refinery worth more than ten billion
dollars in Saudi Arabia in Kuwait
Sinopec has also participated in the
construction of the largest refinery in
the world a project worth more than 13
billion dollars and in a man quick
question have you ever heard of Dharam
well keep this name in mine because it's
likely to become very well known very
soon dokkum is a new city and port that
is shooting up in a part of a man where
there was just hardly anything about
five years ago today it's one of the
largest special economic zones in the
entire Middle East and is here that
Chinese companies are investing billions
of dollars refineries ports airports
hotels offices business campuses we're
talking about a completely new
industrial city located at the gates of
the Houmas straight that is Chinese
shipping companies can operate without
having to enter the Persian Gulf and is
not only a haven for shipping companies
among the billion dollar Chinese
investments there are factories of all
kinds
these are only three examples of the
huge investments China is pouring into
this area of the world back in 2008 the
region received belly 1% of all the
money that China invested globally today
there is Chinese money all over the
Middle East but the Chinese don't only
invest their money they also have no
problem selling all kinds of technology
to these countries especially military
technology for example many of the
military drones and ballistic missiles
that are operated in the region of
Chinese made and all this comes at
precisely the same time as the other
great power the American Empire is
radically changing its strategy for the
Middle East the escape route after
investing hundreds of billions of
dollars and paying a huge price in human
lives the United States seems to be done
with the Middle East especially now that
they're about to achieve full energy
independence between 2004 and 2007 the
United States imported about 12 million
barrels per day but this figure has
decreased to just over 2 million by 2017
that is oil imports have decreased by
80% what's more according to the
International Energy Agency it will only
be a matter of a few years until the
United States becomes a net exporter of
oil and natural gas it's set to become
quite the competitor to the Gulf petro
monarchies while the situation is that
the Obama administration had already
announced its intention to decrease the
United States's presence in the Middle
East and to prioritize the asia-pacific
region meanwhile one of Donald Trump's
greatest promises and along the same
lines
does the USA want to be the policeman of
the Middle East getting nothing but
spending precious lives and trillions of
dollars protecting others who in almost
all cases do not appreciate what we are
doing do we want to be there forever
time for others to finally fight Donald
Trump to achieve this the Trump
administration has a plan to delegate
power to leave the responsibility in the
hands of two close allies and military
leader and a political leader I'm
talking about Israel and Saudi Arabia
[Music]
that explains why since Trump arrived at
the White House his relations with
Riyadh and Jerusalem have become very
very good Saudi Arabia has been willing
to allow it and to forgive everything a
blockade against the country where the
United States has its largest military
base in the region go ahead Donald Trump
tweet support for blockade imposed on
Qatar Congress wants to veto the sale of
weapons to Saudi Arabia's that they
won't use them in the Yemen war will be
having none of us Donald Trump vetoes
bills prohibiting arms sales to Saudi
Arabia the Saudi authorities kill a
journalist who worked for The Washington
Post hi well let's just look the other
way shall we
Trump defends Saudi Arabia ties despite
Khashoggi murder Riyadh is asking you to
take care of the air defense problem
it's all US to send more forces to Saudi
Arabia despite Trump's pledge to reduce
middle-east presence
but the big question is well why well
that's because it would be a great
political success for Trump to get out
of the Middle East and to foster a peace
agreement between Israel and Palestine
which all American president since Jimmy
Carter have tried to do but hold on a
minute because what does Palestine have
to do with any of this well it looks
like the Trump administration wants to
present a peace agreement before the
next elections a peace agreements that
for the first time could be backed by
the neighboring Arab countries which
would force the Palestinian authorities
to accept it that at least is Trump's
idea anyway as you can see some want to
hop off and others want to hop on two
different models to control one of the
most strategically important regions on
the planet the questions remaining are
will Trump's model to control the Middle
East work or will it end up being locked
out of an emergent Chinese domain will
all these actions from the big powers be
good for the region stability or will
they only add fuel to the fire of old
conflicts well leave your answer in the
comments below I really hope you enjoyed
this video do hit that like button if
you did brand new videos every week and
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider Media podcast who
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please consider
joining them and supporting our mission
of providing independent political
coverage and as always I'll see in the
next video
[Music]